wir waren das gemüse für unsere familie
hier fast komplett selber an und damit
das auch klappt bin ich von einem gemüse
viel zu viel haben und von dem anderen
viel zu wenig geht es natürlich
festzulegen wovon man wie viel an bauen
muss und nur darum geht es heute in
diesem video das video richtet sich eher
an leute die sich komplett aus dem
garten selbst versorgen wollen oder so
viel wie möglich selber anbauen möchten
aber ich bin es natürlich genauso toll
wenn du jetzt vielleicht nur ein zwei
oder drei beet hinter deinem haus hast
das ist schon mal ein super start und
ich möchte auf jeden fall nicht dass ich
diejenigen von euch die vielleicht einen
kleineren garten haben jetzt irgendwie
ans bein gepinkelt fühlen von diesem
video sondern das ist auch super und
vielleicht habt ihr ja auch vielleicht
ein gemüse festzulegen dass ihr dieses
jahr nicht mehr im laden kaufen wollt
also so eine kleine challenge zu machen
und malst du überlegen ihr euren salat
komplett selber anbauen wollt wie wir
dann wann aussehen ist damit das auch
klappt also wir sprechen jetzt hier über
die komplette selbstversorgung rund ums
jahr mit gemüse aber das heißt nicht
dass ihr nicht auch mitmachen könnten
zumindest in kleinem maßstab mal
probieren kann wie das denn
funktionieren könnte wenn ihr jetzt sagt
ich bin jetzt mein eigener kleiner
freiluft zu kommen zumindest was salat
angeht so haben wir jetzt schon einige
planungs videos falls ihr die nicht
gesehen habt schaut die auf jeden fall
an die sind unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt und da haben wir
jedes mal damit angefangen dass wir erst
mal einen wunschzettel erstellen mit
denen gemüsen die wir überhaupt anbauen
möchten und das ist natürlich wenn man
sich komplett selbst versorgen möchte
noch mal um so wichtiger dass man dann
einen guten überblick hat was man wann
anbauen möchte so dass wir dann
überhaupt erstmal gucken können
von welchem gemüse wer überhaupt wie
viel brauchen also erstmal eine ganze
schöne hoffentlich sehr lange
beste schreiben mit all den gemüsen die
ihr super gerne bei euch im garten
anbauen möchtet dann sehen wir uns im
zweiten schritt wieder wenn ihr das
erledigt und der zweite schritt ist dass
ihr schaut wieviel ihr denn von diesem
gemüse jeweils ist und ich weiß dass das
manchmal gar nicht so einfach ist das
fest zu legen ich habe mittlerweile ganz
guten erfahrungsschatz wie viel wovon
brauchen so dass ich zum glück jetzt auf
diese erfahrungswerte zurückgreifen kann
aber als ich das noch nicht hatte habe
ich ein kleines haushalts büchlein
geführt wo ich immer mit geschrieben
habe wie viele karten wie zum beispiel
eingekauft haben wie viele weiß
kohlköpfe und so weiter so dass ich nach
12 monaten schon ein richtig gutes
gefühl dafür hatte was wir eigentlich
brauchen wenn ich es mal nicht geschafft
habe die sachen einzutragen habe ich
immer die einkaufszettel aufgehoben
sodass sich das dann gebündelt am ende
des monates noch ausfüllen konnte aber
so haben wir ein supergutes gefühl dafür
bekommen wie viel will dann überhaupt
brauchen und das hat uns ungemein
geholfen diese zahlen festzulegen denn
natürlich gibt es durchschnittswerte
aber ich sag euch gerade wenn ihr
gärtnert dann ist ihr wahrscheinlich
sehr viel mehr gemüse als der deutsche
durchschnittsbürger so dass man sich auf
diese zahl nur bedingt verlassen kann
aber wenn ihr zu faul seite mit zu
schreiben was ich verbraucht dann könnt
ihr einfach mal googlen der gemüse
bedarf eines durchschnittsdeutschen da
gibt es listen für im internet und an
denen könnt ihr euch dann auch
orientieren oder ihr gleich das mal mit
dem ab was ihr so viel gefühl habt also
ihr wisst ja zum beispiel also wie ich
weiß zum beispiel wie essen fast keinen
kohlrabi weil es einfach niemanden von
uns kinder denn irgendwie mag ich baue
zwar jedes jahr ein bisschen kohlrabi an
aber im prinzip ja meistens verhalf dem
beat weil wir überhaupt keine lust
darauf haben wen dann auch zu essen und
das zu wissen da kann man ja schon diese
offiziellen listen ein bisschen nach
seinem
bedarf anpassen so dass man sagt okay
aber erdbeeren davon brauchen wir auf
jeden fall noch viel mehr und das dann
so ein bisschen gegeneinander
verschieden und man ist natürlich auch
wichtig zu wissen dass sich der bedarf
natürlich über das jahr verschieben
gerade wenn jetzt vielleicht lieber
zuschaut der im moment noch das ganze
gemüse im supermarkt einkauft da gibt es
im winter jetzt auch paprika zu kaufen
wir haben jetzt keine paprika weil die
natürlich jetzt gerade nicht wächst im
garten und deswegen gerade für leute die
wirklich ernsthaft in richtung
selbstversorgung gehen wollen empfehle
ich eigentlich immer jetzt schon
anzufangen so zu essen also so saisonal
und regional zu essen als ob das gemüse
aus dem garten kommen würde so dass man
sich auch schon mal darauf einstellen
kann
widerstand nicht so sehr so nahe zu
kochen also man ist muster schon ein
bisschen kreativ werden gerade jetzt im
winter wenn es bestimmte gemüse einfach
nicht gibt und für viele leute ist das
glaube ich ein richtig großer switch den
man da machen muss weil sie es einfach
gewohnt sind das alles zu jeder zeit
verfügbar ist und das ist einfach nicht
der fall wenn man einen gemüsegarten hat
und sich daraus ernährt was natürlich
nicht heißt dass wir jetzt gar keine
paprika essen die haben zum glück eine
ganze menge paprika eingekocht wo wir
jetzt einfach nur glas aufmachen können
wenn wir lust auf paprika haben und sie
haben auch tolle tomatensoße eingekocht
wo paprika mit drin ist aber es ist eben
ein unterschied ob man das draußen
frisch aus dem garten ernten kann oder
ob man es sozusagen schon vorgefertigt
im schrank stehen hat was auch ziemlich
cool ist gerade an tagen wo man viel
stress hat aber man muss sich darauf
einstellen und das natürlich auch in der
anbauplanung berücksichtigen dass nicht
zu jedem zeitpunkt alles verfügbar ist
war für mich auch um zum nächsten punkt
bringt nämlich wenn ihr euren
jahresbedarf plant dann denkt auch daran
dass er auch etwas für den winter
haltbar
machen wollt was ist dann nicht gibt so
dass ihr jetzt nicht nur schaut was ist
ihr denn frisch sondern vielleicht auch
schaut okay wir kaufen im moment noch
paprika im winter wenn wir die nicht
kaufen wollen würden müssten wir im
sommer mehr anbauen so dass wir dann
genug ernten dass wir das dann für den
winter auch haltbar machen können also
dass auch immer im hinterkopf behalten
dass es natürlich total sinnvoll ist im
sommer mehr von bestimmten gemüsen zu
haben die man dann für den winter
haltbar machen möchte und zwar so eine
faustregel oft doppelt so viel wie der
frisch verzehrt weil die zeit in der man
viele gemüse nicht aus dem garten ernten
kann eben ungefähr sechs monate ist und
die zeit wo man viele gemüse aus dem
garten ernten kann auch sechs monate
beträgt so dass man dann möglichst und
uns ja ganz vielfältig aus dem garten
versorgt das zu machen wie das zumindest
wenn du jetzt diese liste erstellt hast
viel zum beispiel einen monat einfach
mal mit geschrieben hast wieder in euer
bedarf aussieht dann schau mal dass du
das auf das ganze jahr hochrechnet du
dass du dann dein jahresbedarf es so
dass du zum beispiel weist wir brauchen
so und so viele karotten oder so so viel
kilo karotten am besten ist es das im
kino zu berechnen das ist einfacher wenn
man jetzt nämlich in den nächsten
schritt geht und sich anschaut wie viel
ertrag man den hochfläche bei welchem
gemüse erwarten kann im biogarten dazu
gibt es wissen im internet ich blende
ich aber gerne mal eine liste ein so
dass ihr das video pausieren könnt und
schauen könnt was da ist für jedes
gemüse steht so dass ihr ungefähr bist
wie viel ernte man pro quadratmeter
ungefähr erwarten kann und das dann
hochrechnen könnt so dass ihr für jedes
gemüse am ende eine quadratmeter zahlen
heraus habt so dass er misst wie viel
bildfläche jeweils braucht also mach das
jetzt mal und dann sprechen wir noch mal
darüber wie man diese zahlen den
bewährten muss also jetzt pausieren
machen fertig dann geht's weiter und
zwar es ist natürlich auch wichtig wenn
ihr jetzt zb schnell wachsende gemüse
wie salat betrachtet dass ihr die immer
wieder
ein und demselben beet anbauen können
darüber habe ich ja letzte oder
vorletzte woche schon mal ein video
gemacht also schaut euch das auf jeden
fall anders nennt sich gestaffelte aus
hat damit könnt ihr euren garten sehr
viel effektiver nutzen so dass er jetzt
nicht denken mit bei den schnell
wachsenden gemüsen wie zb vielen blatt
genießen oder auch karotten rote beete
radieschen sind extrem schnell wachsend
da könnt ihr davon ausgehen dass ihr
drei teilweise 4 oder im falle von
radieschen sogar fünf sätze
hintereinander auf ein und demselben
geht an bauen könnt so dass wir diese
zahl die ihr da jetzt puzzle aus habt
jeweils noch ungefähr halbieren dritten
filtern oder sogar fünfteln könnt um
festzulegen welche garten größe er denn
überhaupt braucht denn es ist ja total
sinnvoll dass man nicht alles auf einmal
erntet außer die sachen die man eben
haltbar machen möchte sondern das ganze
jahr über kontinuierlich erntet und wenn
einsatz radieschen abgeerntet ist dann
könnt ihr da einfach den nächsten
aussehen genau an der gleichen stelle
und dann habt ihr da eine laufende
gestaffelte ernte also schaut euch auf
jeden fall das video an
zur gestaffelten aus weil das ist gerade
wenn man so einen großen ausgeklügelten
garten plan erstellt und so ein großes
projekt vor hat super super wichtig weil
man da im prinzip nur ein drittel der
anbaufläche braucht um dasselbe gemüse
anzubauen wenn man eben gestaffelt
aussieht und anhand dessen könnt ihr
dann euren an bauplan ausknobeln dazu
gibt es ja schon ein video das ich vor
ein paar wochen gemacht habe dass
verlinke ich euch gerne nochmal da unten
und auch da oben so dass ihr das als
nächstes anschauen könnt sobald diese
liste steht dann ist es ganz wichtig
dass ihr jahr für jahr nochmal zurück
schaut auf das jahr das jetzt gerade
hinter euch liegt das hab ich jetzt
gerade für das letzte gartenjahr gemacht
und überlegt hatten wir genug karotten
von welchem gemüse hatten wir zu wenig
von welchem gemüse hatten wir zu viel
ich schreibe das auch gerne das ganze
jahr über immer mit so dass ich für
jeden monat weiß okay hier hätten
eigentlich noch einsatz salat mehr
gebraucht weil da ist der alte schon in
die blüte gegangen und wir hatten keinen
frischen der schon gerne bereit war so
dass man sich eben jedes jahr verbessern
kann und diesen plan noch besser an die
eigenen bedürfnisse anpassen kann also
da immer noch mal zurückschauen und
ihnen planen dann justieren weil es
bringt ja nichts ständig sachen zu
ernten die man nicht essen mag und dann
von anderen zu wenig zu haben so dass es
sinnvoll ist den plan jedes jahr noch
einmal zu überarbeiten und da ein
bisschen anpassungen vorzunehmen sodass
man noch zufriedener mit seiner ernte
ist und jetzt schaut euch auf jeden fall
das video zur anbauplanung an so dass er
weitermachen können wir die nächsten
schritten und wir sehen uns nächsten
samstag wieder biss dann tief